Speaker 1: Earlier in the show I told you all
of the ways in which this protracted fiasco in
the House of Representatives wherein Republicans
have been unable to elect a speaker is bad for
Republicans. Now, that's good. That makes
me happy. I think the Republican Party is
terrible for the country. I think their goals
and ambitions are destructive. I want them to
have a quagmire and to be unable to push
forward their disgusting agenda. However,
I don't want the country to fail. And as a general
principle, not having a House speaker is bad for
the country and it's a national security risk and
it is a source of instability on the bulwarks.
Joe per token Republican wrote an article
touching on some of these issues called The House
is Paralyzed without a speaker creating national
security risks and a shadow shut down. Imagine if
this impasse were occurring in a presidential
inaugural year. And Joe, very precisely and
astutely points out all of the different ways
in which this current status quo is very bad,
including that no one has actually been sworn in
to the House of Representatives yet, even though
George Santo said he was sworn in, he wasn't.
And we'll get to that a little bit later. And I
think it's important just to be clear about the
risks that this presents. It is, I would argue,
even simpler than Joe Per Tacconi lays out.
It's not that he's wrong, but it's even simpler.
This situation in the House where no one
has been sworn in and there is no speaker,
it can lead to a functional breakdown of
the House of Representatives. The speaker
actually plays a critical role in managing and
organizing the legislative process and with no
speaker. How does the House conduct business and
pass legislation? Is it possible to do? It is,
but it's significantly more of a mess within
government. No speaker and no one sworn in. Causes
uncertainty. It causes instability. The speaker
is one of the most powerful and influential
figures or positions in Congress, and the American
confidence in government is certain to decline.
The our perception of the ability of the House to
govern is quite low, accurately, because this is
what they're doing. And then you say, okay, fine.
That's that's that's abstract. But in practical
terms, what could that mean? Well, it can lead
to gridlock or inaction on important issues. When
you think about debt ceiling votes or if there
is a natural disaster of some kind, a crisis,
an emergency, the need for funding in a specific
place, way or form without a speaker and without a
sworn in house, it is significantly more difficult
for the House to actually manage those things,
to respond to unforeseen events. And at the end of
the day, to protect the country's interests. Now,
do I think that Republicans don't care about
that? No, I think at the individual level,
a lot of these Republicans would honestly
say, no, I do care about that. I understand
that I'm concerned. Does that mean they should
compromise on their principles to the extent
that this situation is caused by or catalyzed
by their principles? No, I'm not saying that.
But we have to be factual. We have to be honest.
We have to be realistic. The longer this goes on,
the more instability is accurately perceived by
the American people. And obviously, the longer it
goes on, the higher the chances are that something
could happen domestically, internationally,
and in other ways that would require, in normal
circumstances, the involvement of the House of
Representatives. And they will then be chaotically
scrambling to try to get involved, help or do
something about it. So. The primary interest from.
We have we have conflicting interests here. Each
faction of the Republican Party wants to reign
supreme in terms of ultimately deciding who is
going to become speaker of the House. I get that.
That's politics. They don't want to be seen as the
losers. They don't want to be seen as the ones who
were impotent in trying to impose their preference
of speaker. That's one area. The impact on the
Republican Party we've already talked about.
On the other hand, I hope that I'm accurate in
assessing that the interest of the American people
is to not have to think about the House of
Representatives. And what I mean by that is, yes,
there are some people who are more politically
engaged than others who pay attention to. When
are the midterms? Where is control of the
Senate? Where is control of the House and are
more involved in that, including people like
those who listen to this program, who watch
our clips? The vast majority of the country,
even many of those who vote in the midterms,
don't spend their days and nights thinking about
this stuff. And so it's sort of like referees
in a in a sporting event, if you're noticing the
referees, if you're thinking about the referees,
if the referees are significantly present in
the game, arguably it is because they are doing
something wrong or too involved or whatever the
case may be. You've heard these sports analogies
before and likewise, I would argue if the American
people are thinking about the chaos in the House
of Representatives to the extent that it has been
front and center for the last two or three days,
it is a it is a bad thing. It is the type
of thing where we shouldn't really have
to be thinking about it. The house is there.
There's a natural disaster. They're going to
act. They're going to they're going to help.
They're going to fund. And that's where the
national security risk comes here. We now have a
balancing, a coming together of how long are they
willing to continue this and how tolerant will
the American people be before approval rating,
not only for the House as a body where the
approval rating is always low, but approval for
their individual members of Congress is going
to plummet? I don't know the answer to that,
but I'm guessing we're going to start
finding out about that very, very soon.